give taco in general though like I
talked to guys here and they think I
mentioned in the report earlier but they
think he's a you know a G League type
player and let's see where he goes from
there how do you feel about a taco in
general though like I talked to guys
here and they think I mentioned in the
report earlier but they think he's you
know a G League type player and let's
see where he goes from there how do you
feel about a pellet of my rant and Karen
Jackson two halves highest Jones there
and the thing about Moran is he can play
with taco Paul let's see yeah money huh
Corey Brewer and green work out the last
time they ever worked out at the
University of Florida Billy Donovan
invited me down a lot by fall his third
of the game ball is not coming out to
both low ended up hitting it takes down
the rim watch he tips at first who don't
feel much more comfortable in ten
minutes right Rock number four for taco
fall it would be a blast
tako fall over the alley you know a nice
screen it's really good past running at
his size he's running again run to the
floor well put it down
come on give us another stab we got a
lot of money tied up in stat guys over
there come on go for it
eight points time rebounds four block
you know Knick fans wear you out
well they invented basketball blah blah
blah blah blah fall double figures
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with wheat report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content